the praising Allah
waala sending Salat and
Salam upon his Noble messenger Muhammad
abdah
wasam I would like to
begin by thanking Allah subana
waala for once again
facilitating the like of these
gatherings among the people of the
Sunnah that take
place in a house from the houses of
Allah the
mass the most beloved place or the most
beloved places to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
a gathering in the
Masid where Allah's name is
mentioned and where the sunn of his
messenger sallallah alai wasam is spread
and
propagated and then we thankk those in
charge of arranging the seminar for the
administration of this Masid
M at the head of them our brother Hass
Somali and likewise the rest of our
brothers and our sisters who played a
part in helping to bring the different
aspects of the program
together so we ask Allah subhana wa T to
reward them to bless this
seminar and to continue to bestow upon
the people of Sunnah these beneficial
Gatherings upon Sunnah and upon
Brotherhood and
Sisterhood speaking about this
topic the theme of this conference which
is the signs of the hour and there's no
doubt an important
topic and we know that the hour itself
the Allah has kept its
knowledge hidden with
him and he's not revealed it to anyone
from the creation
it comes in the well-known Hadith
ofel which all of you
know that when jel he asked the M
of inform me about the
hour the prophet sallallah alai wasam he
responded that the questioner has no
more knowledge than the one being
questioned however there are signs
they signs of the
hour and the prophet sallallah alai
wasam he mentioned some of these signs
in this very Hadith
of which our
brother he's going to speak
about and likewise we have in the book
of Allah where Allah
mentions about the about the
hour some of his signs and pance have
already appeared
18 some of these signs being
minor signs of the being minor
signs some of these signs being minor
signs and perhaps some of them a person
may not pay great attention
to and some people they may not even
realize some of
them but there are other signs some
minor
others
major which will no doubt which will no
doubt be alarming to the
believer so therefore these signs they
have been mentioned in the Quran and
Sunnah so that the believer prepares for
the
hour with correct
IM and with righteous
deeds and this is as it has come in the
Hadith of Anis when the man he came to
the messeng of s. wasam he asked the
prophet
about the hour he said when is the
hour the prophet sallallah was he
responded
to and what did you prepare for
it and what did you prepare for
it so
inall among the
things that we hope to take from this
seminar is preparing for the standing in
front
ofel it's preparing hand is preparing
for for the standing in front of
Allah my first talk today dear brothers
and
sisters will revolve around one of the
signs of the
hour which
many of the have considered to be one of
the major signs of the
hour and this is the emergence of Y
and the emergence of Y
and and the proof that they use in
considering the emergence of and to be
from the major sign to the
hour is that which has been established
in
Muslim the Hadith
of he
said
for sallallah alaihi
wasallam
in
Muslim he
said the prophet sallallah he came upon
us while we were reminding one another
he said what are you reminding one
another
of they said we are remembering what
will come of the
hour he said it will not be established
until you see before it 10
signs then he mentioned the Duan the
smoke
theal the beast from the
Earth the Sun rising from the
West The Descent of Isa son of
and and three great sinkings of the
earth one in the East one in the
west and one in the Arabian
Peninsula and the last that is a fire
that will eminate from Yemen and push
people to the area of the M where they
will be gathered for Resurrection n the
Hadith is in Muslim the book of
tribulations and the signs of the
hour
IM from
the he
mentions he quotes
from he
says
he
said what is intended
by
is meaning signs of the
hour he said signs that either denote
its
closeness or signs that denote that his
hair has been
established he said from the first
meaning from the closeness and the scy
they explain meaning what
that that the hour is very close so he
said so from the
first from his closeness the closeness
of the hour meaning when it's very
close is
the The Descent of
Isa and the great
sinkings and from the second meaning
what meaning denoting that the hour is
what is
here is the smoke the
D and the sun rising from the West the
emergence of the beast from the earth
and the fire that will gather the
people so we
examine the words
of these 10 signs that were mentioned in
the Hadi
of these 10 sign signs point to the hour
being very very close or that that the
hour is
here so many of the they've considered
all of these as major signs of the
hour they've considered all of these as
major
signs of the
hour so as for as for y
and then they are an um from B
Adam there are um from Adam
so they are human
beings as they are from The Offspring of
Adam the have
mentioned and as for their
emergence the emergence of Y and
Ma the proofs for this are found in the
Quran and likewise in the authentic
Sunnah which both are sources in which
we as Muslims we derive our
religion without making a a distinction
between the two as both Quran and they
both they are both Revelation from Allah
and this is important as we continue
this
discussion and really it's a matter
which
is from the evidences in the
Quran is what has come
inah a 96 and 97
Allah
mentions until when
and are let loose from their
barrier and they swiftly swarm from
every swarm down from every
Mound and the true promise meaning the
day of Resurrection shall draw
near then she then you shall see the
eyes of the
disbelievers fixedly stared in horror
and they will say wo to us we were
indeed heatless of this nay but they
were they were
wrongdoers and likewise we also have the
verses which most which most of us are
familiar with
the verse is
inah which we recite on
Fridays so Allah States when discussing
the affair
of
and he was a mik
Muslim he was a
righteous King
Muslim who Allah subhana wa T gave
authority to in the land and he used
that
Authority in The Obedience of Allah and
in pleasing Allah subhah wa
taala so the most correct opinion is
that he wasn't a
prophet but he was
a Muslim he was a righteous
King Allah
mentions then he follow then he followed
another
way then he followed another
way
until when he reached between two
mountains where near them he found a
people who scarcely understood a
word they
said verely and are creating Mischief in
the land shall we then pay you a payment
in order that you might erect the
barrier between us and
them he said that which my Lord has
established for me is better than that
which you can give me but help me with
strength meaning men and I will erect
between you and them a
barrier
he said give me blocks of iron
had and then when he had filled up the
gaps between the two mountains he said
blow so when he had made it red as fire
he said bring me molten copper to pour
over
it so they at je were made powerless to
scale it or to dig through
it he said this is a mercy from my
Lord but when the promise of my Lord
comes he shall level it down to the
ground and the promise of my Lord is
ever
true
and on that day we shall leave them to
Surge like waves on one another meaning
and and the trumpet will be blown and we
shall collect them all
together so these
verses which many of you know and read
you read every
week the verses
from prove that Allah subh sub to erect
a tremendous barrier
a between the people and between Y and
Ma who were swing corruption in the
land and likewise these verses
prove that at an appointed
time which Allah
knows and this is when the time of the
hour will draw near then this barrier
will be penetrated and leveled to the
ground as the ayat
states and yet and will emerge at great
speed and they will cause Miss
throughout the
land now what about the
Sunnah we'll read some proofs from
theam as it
relates
to so we already heard one Hadith the
Hadith of
who
huh collected
where Muslim but the companions they
were reminding one another about the
hour prophet he said it will not be
established until 10 signs occur and
from them he
mentioned and so we heard that
Hadith we'll
mention three more authentic
hadiths that have been related to them
well there's more than three more but we
just mentioned
three with mentioning
three
the first I will
mention is the in
the
Muslim Nar
umh daugh of Abu sufyan Abu
sufyan
from
Z that the messenger of Allah s wasallam
entered upon her one day
terrified and he was
saying so the prophet wasam he answered
upon upon her
terrified and he was
saying woe to the
Arabs of a
near evil that's
approaching he said
today the like of this has been
opened from the barrier of
yet and he made a circle like
this
n he said wo to the Arabs of a near
approaching evil today the like of this
has been
opened from the barrier
of and the prophet he made a circle like
this so he made a circle like
this
so Z
said she said I said oh messenger of
Allah will we be destroyed while there
are righteous people among us the
prophet he
said he said yes if sin and evil become
widespread if sin and evil become
widespread the next Hadith we
mentioned is
theith
ofl and in this
Hadith it
says
in this Hadith in
Muslim after
after Y and they will be let loose and
they will swarm down from every mound to
the end of that Allah will reveal to
ISA that I have let out Servants of mine
in which no one has the ability to
fight and which no one has the ability
to fight
so take my
servants to the
Mount so I can be a fortress for
you so I can be a fortress for
you and they will soup down from every
Mound so they will swoop down from every
Mound
and some of them will pass
by Lake
Tiberius which is
intine and they will consume all the
water in that Lake it's a huge Lake for
those who know it still there present
today then the last of them they will
pass by and they will
say
there was once water in this
Lake and then the prophet of Allah
Isa and his companions they will be
besieged they will be besieged there in
that in that
mountain up until the head of a bull
will be better to one of them then 100
din is to you
today SOA and his companions they will
supplicate to
Allah and Allah will send
a which is a deadly
worm a deadly worm into their
necks
and they will all perish they will all
die the death of one Soul me they all
die
simultaneously and then the prophet of
Allah Isa and his companions they will
come down from to meaning from to the
they will come down back to the to to
the ground to the
Earth
and they will not find on the ground not
even a
handspan except the corpses of Y and Ma
will fill the the the
ground so the prophet of Allah and his
companions they will supplicate to
Allah
and then Allah subhana will send
Birds having necks resembling the ban
camel a well-known camel that has a long
neck so Allah will send Birds having
necks resembling the ban
camel and they will carry the corpse
these corpses away and they would
discard them wherever Allah wishes
thatth is is in again
Muslim in the chapter of the mentioning
of
the the third Hadith will
mention the
Hadith of
Abu and in this
Hadith it
comes
so they will emerge upon the people
meaning Y and
Ma and they will consume up all the
water and people will flee from
them and they will shoot their arrows
and another AR their spars they will
shoot their arrows Towards the
Sky
and they will come
back stained in blood those
arrows and they will say they will
say they will say we have conquered the
people of the
earth and now we have overpowered the
heavens and then he
said
so Allah will send against them a
meaning this worm this deadly worm in
the back of their
necks so it would destroy
them and by he whose hand whose hand
Muhammad's soul is
in he said by he whose hand Muhammad
soul is in the animals of the earth they
will be indeed become fat and plump and
overweight from their meat
yeah and thisth is
in
and so we have these
narrations that we mentioned some of
them are Muslim one of them is
in and another iny all of those
narrations are authentic back to the
messenger of s
wasam now we want to speak
about the matter of pinpointing the
barrier built
by and some doubts that have been
circulated regarding these authentic
narration of Y and Ma that's why if you
remember when I said in the beginning
you have narrations that come you have
that which is come in the Quran and
likewise that that you have that which
is come in the Sunnah
both
n as for the place of the barrier built
by then throughout
history some historians have tried to
pinpoint
it it has been said that some Kings have
even sent delegations to this area the
area of the MH the East to find this
said this
barrier but in reality this is a matter
that Allah subhana didn't task us
with following the place or finding the
place of the
said he didn't task his servants with
this
matter we believe in it we believe in
what Allah subh T mentioned in the
Quran and likewise what has come
from the messenger of Allah s
wasallam in our in
particular there have been individuals
who have not trotten the path of the
sah and the imams the
Sunnah as it relates to such narrations
that speak about knowledge of the
Unseen and we find that some have placed
their over
the they placed their intellect over the
text where is the
text the book in the
which are
infallible they must take precedence
over the
intellect because the intellects they're
limited and they
vary and Allah has not given us
intellects so they could so they can so
that they can be Jud or so that they can
be a judge of the Quran and authentic
Sunnah Allah has not given us
intellects so they can be a judge over
the Quran and the authentic Sunnah
meaning accepting things that they
coincide with the
intellect and rejecting things if they
as as some
claim if they conflict with the
intellect and from those in our time in
Quan who went
astray due to his intellect becoming
corrupted by the
freethinkers and by the
philosophers and by the Western
academics is the individual known as
Y and I'm mentioning Y in
particular because he delivered a
lecture or a lesson on this
topic and he presented this
topic in a manner far away from the s or
in a manner far away from how the
S they have presented the
and
likewise what is known from the IMs of
this the of
this he did not tread their
path when speaking about the authentic
Hadith of the prophet
sallam and we're speaking about the the
matters of the
Unseen so from his statements and we
mention actually we'll play them so no
one can say that we put words in his
mouth and said that which he didn't say
we're going to mention some of these
statements
because we'll mention them and then
we'll mention the reputation against
these
statements this works still all
right all right so we play the first
clip the
Earth and from this
fertilization there shall be a time of
great opulence in terms of
food perhaps the most opulent time in
the history of mankind will take place
he's speaking about so he's speaking
about here when uh Allah cleanses the
Earth of Y and this is what he's
speaking about after this time is there
going to be a time of opulence this what
he's saying Gran one
will feed an entire tribe and one leg of
lamb will be enough for a large group of
people in other words things are going
to
change small quantities or maybe it's
not small maybe the ran will be a
massive amount maybe things are going to
change and again we're going to come
back to these interpretations because
either all cryptic phrases and perhaps
we can rethink through them if only to
save the IM of our young men and women
who are rethinking through these things
as well all right tell this is the first
clip so we notice what he
said he said we're going to come back to
these
interpretations because these are all
cryptic
phrases this is how we describe the
of these are all cryptic
phrases and perhaps we can rethink them
through he says if only to save the IM
of our young men and women who are
rethinking through these things
right
cryptic this is what he's
saying all right so he said and we going
to come back to these interpretations
because these are all cryptic
phrases so perhaps we can think think
these through or think rethink through
them if only to save the IM of our young
men and women who are rethinking through
these
things since when is the authentic
narration from the messenger of Allah s
alai wasallam and cryptic phrases since
when and according to
Y these narration from the prophet s
wasallam must be rethought
they must be refought if only to save
the IM of our young men and women as he
says by
Allah this statement is pure
misguidance this statement is pure
misguidance and the only one truly in
doubts about these
statements is
y due to his
intellect becoming polluted with filth
the filth of Western Academia after
leaving Jam Medina then going to these
schools Y and Oxford and other than that
mingling with the orientalists mingling
with the philosophers and those in WT
Academia his intellect has become
polluted so to him these narrations are
cryptic phrases from the messenger of
Allah
s after that we have two more Clips
they're not long but we want to present
these because this again it's a matter
which is this m this path in which he is
on so
next he sarcastically mocks the
classical books of the scholars from
them finding
farfetched what was mentioned that is a
living tribe trapped behind the barrier
built by we'll play this second
clip getting back to time is so limited
have so much to say let's see if we can
summarize
this to be brutally
honest standard medieval interpretation
of Y and Ma is the following this is
what you find in you find it in the
literature of and of and basically this
is the main stream interpretation for
our classical and middle ages of Islam
ever since the beginning of writing
let's say 3 400 up until premodernity up
until going to CE 1800s or whatnot if
you look at any book of any book of
History the notion was the
following and are a bizarre exotic tribe
in the nether regions of the world that
have been trapped by thousands of years
ago and they're still trapped to this
day and quite a few medieval historians
have reported that I know of a friend of
mine who traveled to the end of the
world and he saw with his own eyes the
wall of Y and ma we find this in
respectable Islamic books the notion
that Y and Ma are a living tribe blocked
to this day behind the wall that was
built 4,000 5,000 years ago that wall
miraculously is still there people can
see on the one side and on the other
side you have these Savages that Allah
knows how they're eating drinking
replicating whatnot and they're still
there for eons and eons and
eons this is the standard interpretation
of our Scholars of the tradition not of
the Quran andah you understand what I'm
going to get at okay so look this is the
second
clip
the
his is based upon what is Apparent from
the verses in the book of
Allah and likewise that which is in the
of theeng of the
authentic so how can
y so easily
mock what is coming these
text y then he goes on to draw an
analogy to what was stated by and this
last clip is going to still the deal for
anybody whoever had which I don't think
anybody has any
regarding but he draws an
analogy to what was stated
by and the IMs of again based on what
has come in the book of Allah in the
Sunnah he equates that to fables and
folklore the like of which was believed
by Marco Polo and B and so on and so
forth so we we'll play this one last
clip to Naples to Italy or to Sicily
wherever he was Naples or Italy where
was he andb to uh to Tunisia where he
was from so people didn't travel and
folklores and legends were very common
and it was easy to believe these types
of things that there is this nether
region of and you know if you read by
the way even IB B by the way yeah you
find bizarre fables you find belief in
mermaids and you find weird creatures
and whatnot this is what he believed he
really believed that there are races and
aliens or not aliens but you get my
point this is the the notion of his time
Marco Polo as well he believes these
types of things so it's not surprising
that our medieval scholars believe this
type of stuff
obviously dare I say anybody who knows
science and geography and modern
civilization you cannot believe that
there is a tribe for 4,000 years tra
behind a wall I mean if you believe this
any that's your position I I cannot
believe I'm just being I cannot I find
this very difficult to
believe all right that's his words
right right that's the words
of brothers and
sisters
said play one more thing now pure
misguidance rather is a
matter this
matter how
y rejected which is
clear which is come in the book of Allah
regarding which is come in the authentic
narrations it's a matter rejecting this
is a matter that can lead to
kuur may Allah protect
us yes is clearly from
the meaning what just like the
those who give precedence to their
intellect over the
text which led them to deny the
punishment of the grave and other
things do you see the punishment of the
Grave when you open up the graves do you
see the
Bliss of the Grave when you open it up
we don't see it however the prophet
sallallah alaihi wasallam he informed of
it he doesn't speak from his ha and he's
a
he's the truthful one the one who was
believed we believe in it for certainty
without any
doubt we believe that there's punishment
of the Grave there's Bliss of the grave
and we believe in all the other Affairs
of the Unseen that he sallallahu alai
wasallam he informed
of but with the approach of
Y right that he can't believe that
there's a um trapped behind the wall
built by why
because science because the modern day
geography has improved it how are they
eating and drinking other than that from
the things that he said later on in that
clip Ty has science proved the
punishment and Bliss of the
Grave upon the corrupt philosophy of
then we must deny that too you see how
dangerous this m
is very dangerous
M that you can deny all the Affairs of
the after that based upon the reasoning
the corrupt reasoning
of very
dangerous and this shows how
far Y is from the methodology the of
this and improving this and we're not
going to go for much longer improving
this I want to read the words of the
IM tremendous book listen to what he
says
he
says and the sun explains and clarifies
the
Quran it is the guide to the Quran there
is no analogical reasoning of the Sunnah
and examples and likenesses are not to
be made for it nor is it grasped and
comprehended by the intellects or the
desires rather it consist of following
it and abandoning the ha the
desires up until IM Ahmed says and
listen the end of
theed he says whoever does not know the
explanation of a Hadith and whose
intellect does not have the capacity to
make him understand it then he will be
then it will be sufficient meaning what
to merely affirm thei and have faith in
it since everything from the religion
has been perfected for him it is
necessary for him to to have faith in it
and and to submit to it such as thei of
the so this is there brothers and
sisters this is the manage
of
the
text of the book in the authentic Sunnah
they're infallable we've been
sufficed if you don't understand the
matter then it's merely upon you to
submit and to affirm knowing that the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi he didn't speak from his
desires and this is the way of the sah
so look at the Hadith of
Abdullah when he narr the Hadith of the
fetus being created in the womb of the
mother in the stages of that and from
that
what to the end of that the angel will
come and he will blow the into the feers
and so on and so on so on and so forth
matters of the
Unseen right but even with this he Nar
thisi he
said cuz he was he was ready to narate
that in it are matters he said he the
truthful and the and the believed so
compare this compare this to the man of
Y didn't say well perhaps he meant by
perhaps it means this and perhaps it
means that and perhaps these four stages
mean this and
that he narrated The Hadith that came
from theam he
said and he's the the truthful and the
one who's believed this was the manage
of
the
look what was mentioned by
iMed so compare that to the
of he stated in his
explanation we're refuting some of those
who reject the Sunnah by way of
analogical reasoning same thing done
by when he says that years ago people
didn't travel so they relied on
narrations of this one or that one until
the end of that but now we have signs
the PLS has reached every corner of the
Earth right so I don't don't believe
that he
said when the like of this statement and
the statement wasn't
even bad as this it was bad but it
wasn't bad as this right it was
something about uh matters
of something like upon
this but that which y said is even worse
but what he said when addressing these
individuals
said
he
said according to the degree in which
you hardly turn away from the
legislation of Allah and have arrogance
then based on that will be how much your
Iman decreases
and you're turning away from those
matters could be what leads you to
exiting the religion of Islam to the
religion of
kufur and like
why submitting to the texts and not
countering the text with
ha right he's he's commenting these same
points that we read
frommed he said all this emphasized that
there's no room for one's opinion in the
in wor in the worship of Allah subhana
there's no room for a person's
opinion so it's not permissible for a
Muslim he says so it's is not
permissible for a Muslim to interpret
the texts to mean what he himself seems
to be
correct and this is what Yas has done in
that lecture perhaps y means this
perhaps y means means this and perhaps
it means that and
perhaps right using his own opinion and
his
his his deficient
intellect when he was
asked if the place of the barrier built
by is known we're going to we're going
to play the response
of f we'll translate it quickly insh we
almost
finished
second subh
[Applause]
for
and compare this answer of
a to what was mentioned
by and in his
lecture they asked the
Sheikh if the place of the bar that said
built by is known so the shake respond
he said I don't know of it he said if
one of you knows he said but I don't
know however we believe that it is
present just as Allah La mentioned it
and not everything which is present we
know we know of or con see he said
perhaps Allah kept it concealed until a
particular time and then it will appear
because you have those who say that
there's no set there's no barrier
because of plains and because the whole
earth has been explored therefore
there's no s and if it was it would have
been disc it would have been discovered
sh fan says this is from Pure
ignorance and Allah's Refuge is slau
said there are certain things that Allah
kept hidden or that Allah keeps hidden
people have not incompass the entire
Earth there are things which people do
not know about nor are they even able to
reach planes sometimes crash when going
to certain regions the universe of
Allah's vast and Allah's Dominion is
vast is not a condition that because
something is present that you see it and
Discover it you may not Discover it and
Allah may keep it hidden until a certain
period of time and then it appears he
said look for example and he give he
gives an example uh to the people that
he was speaking to he said the oil the
petrol the oil beneath the Earth he said
the previous generation they didn't
Discover it said but you all discovered
it you benefited from it but before it
he said but before uh before it wasn't
its time but before and meaning of the
past when it wasn't discovered it wasn't
its time yet he said therefore things
only appear at their times they he
mention for every news there's a fact
and you soon will come you soon will
come to
know and there's other but for the sake
of time we'll suffice with that so
overall we believe in ntion that have
come regarding and and the set that was
built
by and we believe that when Allah
decrees that set will be will be
penetrated and they will come out and
they will havoc on the earth and this
will be during the time of The Descent
of until he will until he will
supplicate to Allah Allah will send that
worm which will go into the nexts of Y
and Ma and they will be destroyed and
this is what the prophet he said and
this is what we
believe and as
for and those like him then in reality
we fear for him we fear for y and those
like his labeling the authentic Hadith
cryptic
phrases and him bringing doubt to the
Hadith which is authentic regarding Y
and and them uh knocking at the the the
the set the barrier right and it closing
up and them knocking and closing up to
the end of that until it opens up and
they come out likewise him mocking the
imams of Islam him outright deny the
existence of Y and Ma in the manner that
has been mentioned in the Quran
authentic
this person we fear for his likes we
fear for his
likes in the cautionary tale of
abdah is not far off from our
memories that cautionary tale byd about
Abdullah it's not far from our memories
and we'll end by reading it because
we'll see the similarities between
between and
between we'll see some of these
similarities between
similar a
strike and we end by quickly reading
this this is something compiled by our
brother abass Malik which he entitled
philosophy to
apostasy a cautionary story of
abdah and this is on his website you can
find it if you want to go
back.com so may Allah he starts by
mentioning the statement
of may Allah curse intelligence without
Ean may Allah curse
intelligence without e and May and may
he be pleased with slow wittedness
accompanied by
ta he mentioned this in the biography of
the M the
apostate
stated I heard Abdullah recall his
travels to
Egypt and in Egypt he said I met some
Saudi students of knowledge including
Abdullah
aliim Abdullah Abu yabis and abdulaziz
Rashid as for the first mean
Abdullahi he was infatuated with
newspapers politics books of literature
and the deving opinions of
thinkers this infatuation of
Abdullah would turn his life into a
cautionary story he was born in the
region of Alim in
1907 his father separated from his
mother when he was four so he was raised
in the home of his maternal
grandfather however his grandfather was
unable to care for his family so the
young boy went to work in a Livestock in
a livestock market living almost hand to
mouth later he migrated to Riyad to
reunite with his father who he described
as a staunch
worshipper around the age of 19 Alim he
traveled to Cairo to to study in AAR
University however not long into his
studies he found one of his professors
youus
ofi espousing deviant beliefs and
disparaging the SV
methodology in a series of Articles
published in Nal Islam magazine at De
defended the heretical Sufi practice of
seeking blessings from the dead so the
young student responded meaning
ABD he issued an astonishing reputation
against his teacher
entitled and as a result he was expelled
from the University so look at the
beginning stages of abdah he seen his
teacher right defending this heretical
sui practices uh uh the Su practice
seeking blessing from the dead he
respond he refuted right what did what
did he translate when he was in
Medina who who
remembers
huh or was it was called
correct it's one of the books of mmab I
thought it
was his T was against but he translated
one of the books M I thought it was but
I could be mistaken
huh
n so this is the old
right Contin he says he went on to off
several more works repudiating the
opponents of the S call is ABD including
refuting this the Sufi the sh the
secularists the most wellknown of these
writings was a book
entitled the struggle between Islam and
idolatry a two viant response to
the who attacked Sal in the call of
Islam
muhammd this reputation was extoled by
his contemporaries until it was said
that Alim has offered the DI of Jenna
with this book right they were praising
him he wrote of intentions to pin an
additional value but a third will never
come for after years of defending the
sound Creed and its people alimi stunned
Scholars and common folk alike after
accompanying the people of desires
exploring the doubts of Skeptics and
becoming infatuated with the writings of
philosophical thinkers he would deviate
n apostate and he began authoring books
renouncing Islam questioning the exist
of
Allah and
refuting now a critical study of an
explanation of
likewise so he began authoring books
renouncing Islam questioning the
existence of Allah and refuting all he
once defended right the extreme
scholar he wrote to proceed indeed I
came across the book authored by abdah
entitled
a book which renounces the religion he
goes on to state that before writing
this book Al this is
mentioning the was known for knowledge
and an alignment with the saly
methodology his previous Works were
filled with support for the truth and
and rep and repudiation of the people of
innovation and disbelief until he
stunned the people with this book and
nullified everything that he previously
written about the religion
this reminds one of the statement of is
mentioning misguidance utter misguidance
is to affirm what you used to reject and
reject what you used to affirm n look
again translating the books of M writing
reputations against the J his his thesis
and now after going to yell and going
to Oxford and these in these
universities he's been found saying I
have to re re-evaluate everything that I
learned in Al
Medina that's what he
said that he has to re reevaluate
everything that he learned in Medina
then again we we if we look even even at
his lecture regarding and referring to
him we have to rethink these we have to
rethink them so people W people won't go
as straight no because you have she we
hear them we don't feel no type of way
about him the prophet said it this what
we
believe but it's the she
that he has in his own
chest so now misguidance utter
misguidance it's to affirm what you used
to reject and reject what you used to
affirm it is also it also cautions The
Believer from opening himself up to
thoughts and writings of those who
oppose the correct
belief he beautifully sums this up in
his statement indeed listening to the
people of rhetoric even if you do not
accept their speech will place doubt in
your heart history test testifies to
this for it was after the translation of
the works of the Greek philosophers and
rhetoricians translated in places
like that many were affected by the
thought of the
rist who averted people from
understanding the book and Sunnah
according to the of the P's predecessors
to the speech of Aristotle and Plato at
all so here in lies the danger of giving
currency to statements and ideas that
contradict the way of the Sal and if one
like
known to some of his contemporaries as
the T of his ERA this what they were
calling him known to his contemporar say
the Tam of his eror this was some people
they were calling that one like this can
fall into disbelief as a result of
delving to such ideas that how much more
the small student of knowledge or the
common person so Allah instructs us to
turn away from fals
altogether
and when you see those who engage in
false speech concerning our verses then
turn away from them until they enter
into another conversation and if Shan
should cause you to forget they do not
remain at the reminder with the
wrongdoing not with the wrongdoing
people and the
noble he held that this verse was
revealed concerning the people of
innovation and was quoted as saying
those fast to apostate are the people of
desires and once a man came to him and
said so and so innovated wants to come
and see you he replied tell them no for
the hearts of the children of Adam are
weak and I fear I will hear a word and
my heart will never be the same so
therefore the believer suffices himself
with the two Revelations as we spoke
about earlier the believer suffices
himself with the two Revelations
according to the understanding of the C
safeguards his heart from the doubts and
deving opinions of thinkers and pray
that Allah guides it right mindful of
the prophet's constant
supplication oh turn of the heart to
keep my heart firm upon your religion
one of the companions heard this and
said oh messenger of Allah we have
believed in you and that which you have
come with so do you fear for us he said
yes for the hearts are between two
fingers from the fingers of of Allah he
turns them as as he pleases oh Allah
keep our hearts firm upon your religion
and with this insh we end this lesson
and we ask Allah
keep our hearts firm upon the religion
and protect us from going as straight
after being
guided